[Applaudissements]
enregistrez voilà elle sera de retour
aux halles au taux de 2 3 heures du
matin je vais clore une animatrice oui
mais moi je vais vous dire monsieur vous
le dire je vais vous dire franchement
j'ai du mal à trouver un
il a du mal à assumer sa faiblesse je
vois pas qui alessandra sublet je les
adore on me dira ils n'ont elles
m'excite pas l'estomac c'est comme ma
soeur alexandra public j'adore ces
barils série je vous dis quoi
daniela daniela lumbroso au genou
l'avait poussé par ailleurs j'aime bien
daniel lumbroso jean latour bas parce
que parce que parce que vous aviez parce
que on est retombé avec l'équipe et ça
nous a fait le week-end quand même bon
ne reviendrai sur une tablette accordé
beaucoup d'interviews à l'époque de m6
web et notamment vous avez accordé une
interview à un magazine qui s'appelle
fans de nom c'est sûr et c'est vrai et
on a retrouvé alors ça en vue
oh les coups quand des dons pour elles
différentes bulles avec évidemment
différent ouest dont la question sur
votre maman sexy et votre plasma vous
disais que c'était daniela lumbroso
donnait on vous en suis regardé les
ailes mexique grave
j'adore sa voix et son physique il ya
aussi moyen que vous me la présentez jeu
les refus de plus bah oui ben je leur ai
je droit et à droite il ya quand même
deux trois petites questions qui
méritent qu'on sache qu'on s'attarde
nouvelle chance seconde petite copine
oui alors allé au oui oh oui je me lasse
vite faudrait qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
roulement oui j'ai du mal à finir mes
histoires d'amour mais je n'aime pas
parler de ma vie privée je préfère faire
un gage
j'en ai déjà parlé là en fait il ya
d'autres choses saison accepterais-tu de
poser nue dans un magazine
bon oui oui bah vous savez vous appelez
même à ce qu'on vous appelle
ah oui d'accord mais oui mais
et puis alors pour technique de grades
de drague faire marrer les filles parce
que femme qui rit à moitié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]